alright hey welcome to Android developer
office hours and Joe Fernandez from the
Android developer relations team and i'm
joined by hi everyone my name is Kara
John's hi everyone my name is Juanita
beta hey my name is Alex Lucas all right
and yes we are all members of the
Android developer relations team here in
Menifee California we do have a special
guest Bruno is visiting us from our
South Paulo office so he just literally
walked in the moment ago so i think it
is that your first time joining us here
on the air right yes it's the first time
drop joining you on this side of the
camera well welcome thank you so let's
see why don't we get started with
something off moderator actually before
you get started I should point out that
this is in fact a non-confidential
Google oh it isn't is it folks it is so
last time we were here actually I had
this tablet with me and some people
thought and thought it was actually some
sort of confidential undisclosed tablet
and that's actually not the case this is
a it's an oboe seven paladin it's a nice
little sub $100 android tablet that i
was using last week to read questions
off of so yes you can actually go out
there and buy this right now nothing
secret or anything like that we know
where i'm at these would like to think
so anyway so why don't we get started
with moderator question number one the
Android design guidelines are extremely
hard to follow without the action bar
support for pre honeycomb devices this
is true why hasn't a bit this included
in the support baggage what is
recommended for the following design
android design for these devices this
would be a great Roman Nurik question
but Rome is not with us today anybody
else wanna chat tackle that one yes so
we certainly know that there's demand to
go and have support for action bar in
the support library it turns out that
there were some technical issues that
didn't allow us to do this it's not
quite as simple as just going and
copying the code ova
so yeah for now our recommended approach
is to use actionbarsherlock and so I was
reading through the comments on here and
it seemed like the author is concerned
with that was that he wasn't sure what
the license was for actionbarsherlock
and mind are sitting is that is in fact
licensed under the apache license so
that's a it's a permissive license
you're free to use it in your code and
it works pretty well so right now our
recommended approach is to use
actionbarsherlock we can't talk about
the future of the support library but we
do know that there's a demand to go and
add this feature so okay Thank You
Trevor let's take one more moderated
question here the main screen and the
Play Store is a clever twist with the
categories tab it fills only half the
screen on a tablet how is this done
anybody want trying a lot one all right
so yeah yeah a second with Dan actually
I think you're talking to you right so
yeah yeah you weren't you after this one
alright so we actually took a look at it
it's not a the the term tabs a little
bit of a misnomer they're actually
really just yeah it confused me I
couldn't figure out what this question
is actually talking about well I thought
you know maybe you know when you you
know click on the apps button you know
you have that view pager there and you
can just life swipe left or right and to
me that's what I think of as tabs there
but as far as we can tell us not with
the the person asking this was actually
talking about but I think the confusion
was the first ask Ashley thought these
were tabs in which case it would be a
set of tabs vertically stacked in a tiny
chunk of the screen somewhere in the
middle which would be very difficult to
do and I don't think we actually have
that kind of functionality built in
other they're really just buttons though
yes this is the very first page of the
app you let you launch google play and
you have four buttons hey you know apps
yeah this is music and movies member
Berkeley and yes they're literally just
buttons they might look like tabs but
there's nothing special about them and
then you can just use you know normal
you know normal lab managers to go and
you know align them however you want so
so the secret is make buttons look like
tabs and then you can do whatever right
yes the secret of you I is just make
everything do what you wanted to do by
making them all on tapped right or but
there's no or buttons depending on what
you wanted it
all right looks like we've got somebody
in the Hangout one of our regulars do
you have a question sir yes I've got one
name I need to do a image views that go
for me you know the changes the picture
from zero you know 12 the number zero on
the screen and then it goes from zero to
100 in three seconds okay 100 and so you
wanted to count out to 103 seconds yes
it's nice to go from you know 0 1 2 3
all the way to 100 but can you tell us
why when you need specifically an image
feel for that or why is it that you need
an image viewer not the standard at XP
or other with you well it doesn't have
to beat image with as to be something
that presents a picture because it's big
shells because its engine numbers that
were designed for the app okay
understand okay so I mean actually
possible that's going to be roughly 30
frames per second which is perfectly
within the refresh rate at the screen
the only limiting factor there i think
is to be how quickly can you go and load
these images off of your storage and get
them into you into memory and into a
place that you can go and copy them into
your video buffer so i think as long as
you preload everything there shouldn't
be anything really technically
challenging about this did it give us an
estimate about how big those bitmaps are
I mean as a full screen bitmaps or are
they just tiny images there a PNG's
right but how are they and let me just
check that and then one more thing I did
all that is something that day I know
that all the image views of 0 to 9 and
just the day i paid with the visible and
invisible you know based on the number
that i need to show but that they took
nine seconds to get from 0 to 100 right
yeah well i think in that case the
really tricky thing is that you've gone
in I mean that's a lot of data to be
trying to go and load up all at once
yeah the best case scenario would be if
the bitmaps are small enough that you
can hold them all in memory and then
just display because if you have to swap
them back and forth
from memory yeah you may have them on
that too but you're gonna be modifying
your layout yeah and when you modify the
layout that's a lot more complicated nuh
stopping a an image out there's actually
a lot of structure behind it that has to
adjust right we have the entire layout
tray that we got to go and refresh yeah
so uh another thing that I held about
you tell me maybe it's better to you
something that scored them one second
let me just see what what it's called a
level list could that possibly faster
the speed a little less trouble yeah
that's well that's usually not know what
it's intended for but I don't know if
you could sort kajol it into doing that
another option would be to just extend
directly a canvas yes I suppose think
that is so what you're essentially doing
is you're playing full screen video or
there's a full full frame rate video
right and you know the way our video
players work cuz they don't actually go
and have an image you that they keep
updating this have essentially a canvas
that they're drawing to and really that
that's going to be your key here right
so make sure that you're not every time
you have a new frame of your video which
is essentially what this is that you can
just go and draw that in flakes without
having to go and modify your view
hierarchy so and really the easiest way
to do that is going to be to go and use
a canvas and just go and you know paint
your pixels right on top of whatever
hurry on the screen exactly and that way
also you can skip the step of having to
clear it too right so if you even if you
reload the same or if you reuse the same
image you right you're gonna have most
likely actually no I don't think if you
just update in place out to get one hour
then you wouldn't have the other whole
layout overhead right so you might be
able to get that too I mean it's still
going to be a bit heavier than if you
just have a canvas and paint it directly
so that's going to get you the best
performance but you might be able get
away with just reusing the same image
you and updating that the the source is
being fed into it each time and of
course be careful about keeping a lot of
defense in memory since there there's a
memory limit right well it's not ready
to lend it over with the best equipment
when I just checked the file sizes of
those numbers each one is about some
twin named fall 27 a kilobytes yeah but
be careful that and it gives them
uncompressed in memory so the file size
may not reflect how much memory it
actually takes when you're loaded into a
bitmap object so but I mean assuming the
images are not very large it should be
all right yeah and in me and make make
sure that you're not scaling them too I
mean 30 frames per second you might be
able to get away with it but yeah it's
cutting it close I would try and make
sure that whatever resolution be
displaying these on your screen is the
resolution that they're stored locally
and then you keep that that processing
pipeline as short as possible between
your discs and your GPU hmm I say okay
thank you China you can consider OpenGL
well yeah but then that's you know
that's the last option on the menu it
should be possible to open jail I mean
it it's video yeah you know a video does
take a bit of work but it is entirely
possible without having to resort to
native code okay or open to jail for
that matter which is not always native
but yes okay okay fanuc you fell down
great thanks for the question let's take
another moderator question here there
needs to be a way for apps on API
11-plus to hide this system bar at the
bottom truly go fullscreen not just
change the navicomp that's an example
how to bring the system back it can be
the press the power button I think we've
got something yeah so so there's already
we do so in I believe in honeycomb yeah
I did something which we called light
tack mode which is those little dots at
the bottom that you're seeing so the
idea there was to go and give you a way
to go and take away a lot of the OS
chrome not chrome OS OS chrome the
dividual elements thrown by the OS and
you know basically give you more of a
just a clean minimalist environment or
through things like playing videos
reading books etc in Ice Cream Sandwich
took that step further and add the
ability to do allow apps to go fully
full screen so you do have the the old
light tap mode that's still an option or
you can say
hide the system bar entirely it is I
can't remember the API call off the top
of my head I can look at up here in a
moment I looked it up right before the
show but I've already forgotten it but
it's just a flag that you go and use for
a sec system UI visibility now the catch
with this though is the system bars will
replace the home button and the home
button is sort of important that's sort
of a sacred button that should never
ever be hidden or overridden and we make
sure that that never happens so if you
are actually saying I want to hide that
we provide a mechanism to go and pull it
back up and what we decided that we
wanted you for that was make it so if
you tap anywhere on the screen your
system back comes back up the use case
for this is playing for example a
YouTube video or any video for that
matter you get rid of the video but if
you tap some more just like the video
controls come up so does your home
button so that's the behavior you get
automatically when you use that and
because the home button is sacred there
is no way to override that behavior so I
was reading through the comments and you
can suggest that maybe you want
something else like using the power
button or you know there are various or
having a gesture there's a lot of
different approaches you could use for
this but we decided that the use case we
want for this because it really is the
simplest one and this the one users are
already familiar with from videos is if
you tap on the screen the home button
comes back I know you said in your
comments there's for a handwriting
recognition program you want to use use
jennie-o like for detecting gestures and
you want to make sure some use
left-handed doesn't hit the home button
probably the best feedback I can think
of there is maybe we should move the
home button to the other side of the
screen is option but that's good
feedback for our you 2i team but
unfortunately I don't think that there's
really any way that I can think of to go
and get the behavior you're looking
forward at home buttons completely gone
yeah I know my understanding of that is
they don't want to take away those
buttons because that's like the one
thing that can get people out of
whatever they're doing at the moment
yeah we want to make it very very
findable right right the home button is
the one button that will always get you
back the back button can be overridden
you might not have any other apps in
your app switcher the home button will
always get you home and so that needs to
be very very discoverable right now so
you
India in the good old days of physical
buttons you couldn't do it with the home
button anyway so that that part of the
screen you should just consider that
that part of the screen as as a part of
the hardware it's a part of the device
if user needs to oh it's an essential
part of the device there's not much we
can do about that right is that works as
designed so let's head off to the next
question we've got a couple more people
in the Hangout any of you guys want to
ask questions were those for those
regarding day the baby's questions I was
looking into I was using me accentuated
just a plain old java library they were
using external I zabal for a lot of
their serialization I was wondering you
know for passing it through bundles and
you're using x-rays and so forth how
well would external I zabal work
compared with our swivel so I compared
with what parcel didn't Lee use so your
question is at the performance of
serializing rivers is possible well not
I mean Carrie elizaville kind of or just
going to using a lot of reflection and
everything but you know we make sure
lives of regression to find the
derivation yourself and so ditch should
theoretically perform quite a bit faster
for a lot of the same reasons that
parcel will works a lot faster ok I
could see that working um yeah or I
consider making sense I mean a lot of
the additional classes we've added on
Android ratted specifically because of
performance constraints so yeah I think
you're going to get the best performance
across level why
external I zabal I mean I haven't
actually used externalize will myself I
mean what you're saying makes yeah I
mean it looks like it's a lot more
because you know you're not supposed to
eat as possible for you know saving to a
file or something like that it's mainly
for inter process communication whereas
external I zabal actually can be used
for you know writing to a file and stuff
like that you know that's correct but
exercisable also i mean lets you specify
what file format you want correct right
I think so yeah we're as possible I
imagine is going to have some very
minimalist in-memory format that doesn't
make any sense outside of the devices
you know context so for that reason you
probably have a little bit more overhead
with externalize Bowl because you have
to go in you know possibly map to say or
do will be mapping to some other file
format right that's not necessarily
optimized for consumption on the device
okay I mean I think if you've ever
looked at protobuf protocol buffers
which we use internally at Google same
basic idea there right the way proto
buffs are so fast is because you have
this specification which maps from
fields to eventually by the raisin so
unless you have the protocol file which
does nothing and everything you can't be
there there is no way to Dakota just
look like a random block on I guess but
because of that you get really good
performance at the cost of portable all
right thank you yep thanks for the
question all right let's take another
one from moderator what is the life span
a static block in the class or in an
Android app more specifically when
exactly is the code in the static block
run and when are the variables nulled
out this question from n hot in
Jerusalem what do you guys think all
right so as well so first I think we
have to define what you mean by static
block right i mean there's different
places you can use the static keyword
but so let's say that it's just you know
simplest case you have some static
variables that are included with your
class right let's thetic open curly yeah
yeah yeah same thing so in that case
it's as far as i understand it I mean
the rules are an Android of the same as
in Java so your your variables are going
to get initialized when the vm loads
your class which would I believe be as
soon as you launch your application yes
depending on your usage yeah it might be
the case that a particular class is
loaded later so I wouldn't try I would
try not to rely too much on this
behavior and then just use static blocks
for things that should really be static
and it shouldn't matter what exactly the
life cycle is right so I wouldn't rely
on that too much the the general rule
though that should be followed is it
follows the same as its standard Java
conventions right so I mean I've seen
interesting cases where it's some sort
of lot free singleton tight like design
pattern where you use the fact that a
private that a member variable in a
private class even if it's static
doesn't get initialized until it's
accessed for the first time and it's I
mean it's a handy optimization but
you're you're relying a little bit too
much on on you know black magic yeah and
be sure that well static books should be
used sparingly so if you have like large
chunks of code into your static lots
there may be something along the code
design so the first thing that it would
ask myself is whether I need or not to
have these very complex static box yeah
and they enter the second part those
questions part when the very versatile
Arnold out I mean that would be when the
class is unloaded from the vm which i
believe in most cases is going to be
when your process ends one is right
which is not when your activity goes on
screen of course so but it could be it
could be a nick my copy it entirely
depends on what other one other parts of
your act of your application you have
and what's running and what settings you
said your manifest and whole host of
things that makes it actually very
complicated topic
the short version is if we'll get
unloaded at some point and I wouldn't
rely on him again if you have to rely on
that for correctness there might be
something wrong with the co.design okay
thanks for that question let's go to
hang out again a couple more joggers
anybody else get a question that's
actually in there um this a lot of
people always say that android is a lot
worse than iOS simply because of the
poor actually you're gonna have to speak
up a little bit we can actually barely
hear you in here just a little closer to
the mic or a little louder please can
you hear me now yes much better thank
you I tend to find a lot of people on
the internet say that android is worse
than iOS due to the app quality and I
was just wondering if the Android team
were thinking about incorporating
something to help tidy up the Android
code for new developers so if there's
code that's out of date would it
possibly be capable of tidying up the
code for them to help new new developers
so it's very what context are you
thinking that were you thinking like
what what code will be tidied up here um
but basically a code that it says is i
can't think of the exact word that it
uses but when i'm developing an eclipse
from time to time i come across things
where there's a line through the code
and it says this is out of date Oh
deprecated deprecated that's the one
sorry yes sir I mean I don't think
that's really an app quality issue
that's that's that's SDK issues and
that's maintaining backwards
compatibility right now we can trees
alee remove those because if there are
older apps and we remove those they will
stop compiling and or stop working
depending on how it's done and we do we
do progress on maintaining a backwards
compatible Android so we want to go and
keep those around as long as possible
even though we display warning saying
please don't use these but I think
that's a completely orthogonal issue to
Africa
to app quality right just just when your
regardless of whether or not using
deprecated SDK calls as an end user I'm
not going to see that right I'm going to
see the the the UI that's been designed
and you lady quality of the assets and
you know what you I conventions I'm
using and what my applications
navigational structure is right
performances performance is another very
important issue yeah does it though do
what I wanted to do etc that's sort of
that's a good quality yeah how well does
it conform to the UI conventions too I
mean this is something we think about
you know we just recently released our
Android design site which goes into
quite a bit of detail about what
different conventions are used
throughout Android and what UI developer
should be following we've also been
doing quite a bit of work on the
framework side ever since honeycomb oh
you know we've released our holo theme
with the goal of both giving a visual
refresh with the Android platform but
providing a single theme this guaranteed
to be present all devices even if the
rest of the system theme has been
modified or customized by OEMs so you're
always guaranteed on a honeycomb when
your device to have the holo theme
present but really a lot of the ends so
I mean we're trying to put the tools out
there to go and make sure that app
developers can write all the apps and
make sure that you follow the same
guidelines but part of it too is just an
app developers have to follow those
guidelines you know we can only do so
much on our end all right we do use a
sorry I just happen to be a relatively
new developer myself on the Android
platform so I just want to make sure
that I get everything as good as
possible because it it's I'm only
developing a simple SMS scheduler up at
the moment I just want to make sure that
customers are use Android devices feel
that they get as good quality ups as
people on other platforms so yeah so in
that case I would definitely take a look
at the Android design site how are you I
looks it's going to be one of the most
important things as far as how users
perceive the quality of the application
and then I'd say that the second i have
to say i thoughts i do quite like the
whole
both you I see my use that myself and a
lot of the people I've asked for
feedback say the DUI looks great so
thank you for the holo theme that you
introduced yeah i mean i should add to i
mean not just specifying the holo theme
is not going to be enough right that'll
go to the visual look and feel but of
course you know how you actually design
your UI matters a lot too and we can't
do that for you automatically right and
we know how do your buttons look you
know how do you structure your action
bar you know how have you hired a
graphic design or they go into your
graphics because most programmers are
actually not that good graphic design
but um except for oh except for 07 Roman
is very good at leas for hire but yeah
than anything to you know pay very close
attention to performance I think it's
easy to overlook that probably the
easiest thing to do is go into developer
options if you have a newer phone and
turn on strict mode if you have an older
phone there's a line of code you can add
your application do the same thing and
whether that that will do is it will
flash the border through of your screen
read every time you perform a blocking
i/o operation on the UI thread and so
that's probably the most commonly
performed mistake and what that will
causes it'll it'll make your appt slow
down will cause a visual lag and stutter
whenever you do things like you know
read from leaking disk and I believe
newer phones will even actually crash if
you try and access the network from
gluon even if you don't have strict new
enabled the you estimate you should or
should only be doing you I from the UI
thread anything else should go into a
background thread so also a pretty
important resource to read is the best
practice so if you go into our developer
tool and calm and going to deb guyot we
have a whole section on best practices
and that includes performance that
includes responsiveness so there's a
whole lot of material there that is very
important to make sure that your apps or
as pleasant as possible to the user the
other very important point is to make
sure that your application is intuitive
to the user because nobody's we need to
read a manual to figure out how your app
works and sometimes as developers it's
easy to trick us into check ourselves
into believe you that our app is
intuitive because we know how it works
but sometimes it's not going to be as
intuitive to
user yeah austin area to make is just a
give your app to a user who has never
used it before and wash them and see if
they can figure out how it works if they
cannot if they look puzzled then that
there's probably a problem I see which
of you I labs here at Google where we
worship two rooms in one room which is
you know setup is just a room with a
computer and then a one-way mirror and
then a bunch of Engineers watch the user
performing common tasks on the other
side now not everyone can afford a a you
know fancy term setup but it really is
as simple as just giving your act
something and say hey could you try
doing you know X and don't tell them how
to do it just watch and see what they do
and see where they get confused exactly
alright so move on thanks for the
question this come back next week and
let us know if you've got more questions
about it maybe we can do some follow-up
on it thank you for the response tab and
actually one more thing that I should
note we do have a show on Friday called
the f of you and if you look through the
moderator I believe we do use the same
moderator for it I think we do I believe
if not check our Google+ page and you
can find a link to it but you can submit
your your app for review and we have a
panel of engineers will go through and
they'll tell you what looks good and
what could be improved and so if you're
really striving for quality you know get
getting some critique that way you know
just like artists ask ask people for a
TKE for two year for a critique same
thing with apps right ask some peers
including us and we can go ahead and
take a look through your app and tell
you what we think could be better okay
thank you very much so I believe that
lets friday at 1pm but if you want to
get your app on their you do need to
submit it in advance so there's a
moderator queue I be sure to follow
Android developers on google+ then we're
going to announce those a hang us there
okay thank you okay thanks for the
question and the answer is there let's
go to moderator for another question
here absolute layout is deprecated and
we're told to use relative layout
instead but relatively I had a very poor
support on the graphic editor I think
they named a layout editor in Eclipse
there yeah part of agt should i stop
using the graphic editor or just use
absolutely have any way the internet is
do not use absolutely
do not use it please the problem with
absolute layout is it doesn't work when
you have devices with different screen
sizes and android has devices with
different screen sizes and therefore you
get apps that look really bad this ties
in with our whole conversation about
quality um so yes you absolutely should
use relative layout or honestly use
anything except absolute layout
absolutely i guess probably the worst
choice period so on how you really feel
that but should i use absolutely yeah
baby but yeah and admittedly our layout
editor doesn't work in all use cases and
as your app you I guess more complicated
it might not work for you personally I
find it works really well to go and get
the initial prototype of your UI sit up
and then from there you'll have to tweak
things in XML I think all really good
applications if you have a good UI
you're going to wind up having to write
xml by hand yeah so it's all about
making sure you're targeting multiple
devices and don't assume you've got one
size fits all for your layout yeah it's
gotta make sure it moves and its
dynamics oh yeah and I hate to make this
comparison but yes it think the layout
editor as you know microsoft frontpage
or dreamweaver right it's really good
for getting a quick prototype built but
you know most if you're doing your site
design hopefully you're not doing the
whole thing in green weaver yeah all
right and then not not to not to say
anything bad about either those programs
actually like dreamweaver no it's a good
idea grab the code view way more often
exactly so that's one of the things I
liked about Dreamweaver they did make it
very easy to switch in the Dakota view
nothing against remover I've used it a
lot myself but I know some people like
myself back in high school who have
written some tights entirely using the
yeah not so much ridges click right yeah
using the wizard to do yes now the truth
comes okay so moving on then let's see
we've got some more folks in the Hangout
anybody on the Hangout itself once we
have a recession but we have a chat
questions excellence on Android security
see Tony OH&S have we had a trend I have
a question about transitional drawable
if you get a chance we have a chance we
do have a chance here is your chance to
ask the question hi guys a transitional
drawable just to do a quick transition
between three gradients which drawable
xml and he runs for 10 10 seconds
unfortunately doesn't seem to them that
fires once it's completed so happens I
have a countdown timer running at the
same time and the way I'm getting round
is that Jerry for 10 seconds reverse the
transition again and wondering if that's
really the best thing that should be
using or if there's something else that
you'd be doing to make this simple
animation can you tell us a little bit
more about what the what is it you're
trying to do it is there something
you're displaying something on-screen
obviously but what's the what's your
goal for it yeah you just the entire of
the relative layout to display a radial
gradient which is used for my baby silly
now I just changes color so I goes from
green to yellow to red and then reverses
itself hmm well I'm drawing a blank on
any of you guys want to try that one
yeah very good answer there either here
I don't know off the top of my head so I
think we might have to quantum ask you
to do a stack overflow question for us
so you can show us the code and see and
tell us what the problem is i mean if
you can add that had a question into
moderator and give us a link to the
stack overflow we could probably take a
look at it that way is it exactly that
we don't have it again today Deborah I
actually you might remember the best
place to put it because the moderator
will close at the end of this show so
just put it was a comment to this video
this video right well not enough power
affair just this one series moderator
walk right thanks
right thank you Tony appreciate the
question all right let's go moderator
again molo from Portland Oregon desks
i'm working on a widget that has a list
view how can i manually update a list
button press I've tried to set the
action of an intent through an app
widget manager action that would get
update but nothing ever happens is there
anything i'm missing probably yes the
question is what pretty missing so yes
there is actually a method you called
indicate that your data source has been
updated let's notify data set changed
yes that's the one I think there's
actually a special version for widgets
as well all right now I think it's like
on widget no to my data set or would you
not notify dataset change day I wish I
had a computer to happen with me or I
had look at the exact verbiage for it
but you get the idea look look for data
set changed on dataset changed and
you'll find probably a couple methods
that will help you with this and then
once you send that there's a callback
that you'll implement inside of your
widgets the delight to respond to it I
think I'm spoiled by intellisense but
that's one of those methods that I know
exists but I can never for the life of
me remember the name of mmm it's like
notify a quintal space right I just type
dot notify and wait for Eclipse to
populate something for me I think I need
to start writing the exam before the
show list of methods that I won't
remember what I'm actually in front of
the camera yeah that's gonna be a large
list yeah well the right list of methods
that I've noticed from the questions
I'll forgetting from the camera okay
Lourdes alright next question we've got
a chat question de vida i'm going to
terribly mess up this two-way old i'm
just gonna have to correct me on that
one I'm not gonna direct to security but
sorry will say again I'm not going to
correct my last name is gonna be too
difficult I think yeah okay you want to
tell us what the question is yeah so I'm
basically developing a rest api which
i'm going to put on the internet which
is exposed true ssl and I've been giving
it a lot of thought about having some
kind of n2
security strategy I think on the server
side I have pretty much everything
covered but i was wondering on a mobile
device is it a correct assumption that
on a rooted android phone or a
jailbroken iphone whatever it is
impossible to secure properly there will
always be a way for a malware app or a
hacker to get into the device decrypt
stuff I said we're actually stop you
right there are camera reset in the
middle of your question and we didn't
hear most of that so what ifs to start
from the beginning sorry about that is
it a correct assumption that a rooted
android phone is inherently insecure
that there is no way to properly secure
a rooted android phone ah ok so yes the
question is is it possible to have a
secure rooted phone or they always
insecure no just always assume that a
rooted phone is insecure yes that is
correct yeah so the Android security
model defense depends on sandboxing apps
by process ID as well as by user IDs
when you install an app the system will
assign it a unique user ID for that
particular application and the problem
is is if you root your phone and you
allow applications to run this route it
means every application can read from
every other application sandbox and so
you've completely disabled Android
sandboxing functionality which is in
fact insecure so yeah now there are some
apps like super user out there which
attempt to mitigate this by adding some
hooks that will pop up a dialog and
giving you like an allow denied choice
whenever an app requires root permission
and that helps to go and improve this
the problem with that though is you're
depending entirely on making sure that
there's no privilege escalation bugs in
the superuser app and I have never done
an analysis on this myself but I know
some of our security folks have and they
had a few concerns I can't really speak
any more to it than that because I don't
remember but I guess my point is yeah in
given that I've never are so given that
it's sort of a sketchy area to begin
with and I don't think a lot of people
have their eyes on this code I am sort
of loathe to trusted to inherently and
if you have if you really do care about
the date of your phone the easiest thing
is just not to root it now that being
said I there's not too much that you
actually need to read your phone for I
understand wanting to unlock your phone
to put alternative firmwares on there
but actually putting ruin your phone is
only useful in a few specialized cases
so I'm just a curiosity where's that
you're trying to deal with it requires
root I don't require root at all but I
know that certain consumers of my rest
api will run on a rooted phone ah yeah
so yeah me so and yeah I mean that is a
concern if your app is running on a
rooted phone yeah that phone is problem
is is not as secure as a phone that has
not been rooted but if we turn the
question around and so we can assume
that a non rooted android device is
perfectly secure if for example I have I
would not say perfectly secure we can
say perfectly secure to anything yes as
somebody who's studied uh you know
computer science i can say that i don't
know of any system that was perfectly
secure I know systems are very secure
but I don't know if needed are perfectly
secure perfectly to get me out of our
asymptotes where you can get clothes but
it doesn't exist so uh in terms of yeah
i think android security is very good
but I'm not ever going to call anything
perfect because I know later on I'll
wind up regretting that if for no other
reason than you could treat the phone as
though it were not rooted and then
someone could come along with the phone
well or rooted phone could pretend to be
unrooted your own then you have other
fun things like tempest attacks right we
have some some shady guy in a van with a
giant antenna pointed your phone right
and they're reading the electrical
signals as your screen refreshes right
there are all sorts of fun little
side-channel attacks that yes what is it
as beautiful are these five vowels
anyway so did you have any fun more
follow up on that or we suppose what
would be like the the general security
guidelines that that we would need to
implement for example I have this kind
of remember me functionality because I
don't want the user to type in their
username passwords every half an hour or
every day so I need to store some kind
of credentials on the phone okay so like
I can I can store for example an
authentication code that comes from the
REST API I can encrypt that on the
device I can obfuscate my coat would
that be a sufficient level of security
for a mobile app or yes I say
recommendation I give is to yeah so
basically what you're saying you create
an authentication token so the very
first time you login these will provide
their user and password of course that
jelly is over an encrypted channel yeah
and then you return back a token that
you save on the device instead and then
if the user ever changes their password
via your web app or you know whatever
change password functionality you have
revoke all the old tokens and make the
user retentate on those devices and so
what that means is if the though most
importantly it means if somebody does
mean to compromise your credential store
it means the users plaintext password is
interviewed and yeah the problem is
users are usually pretty bad with their
passwords when they change them a lot of
times listen you change it by one digit
or worse they'll go and we use that
password across the lot of different
sites now and therefore if somebody
discovers your plaintext password for a
user that's very bad or as if they just
have an auth token you can revoke that
auto can every issue later and you know
that mitigates a lot of the risk there
now as far as investigating your code
that's you know it helps in some cases
and that does make it a little bit
harder to go and understand your code if
you run it through a deep compiler but
the problem is if somebody really is
determined and there are a lot of
determined people out there who enjoy
trying to go and figure out how things
work that you know if my
take them you know instead of a day it
might take them a couple of weeks but
you know codification won't actually
it's not going to prevent somebody from
trying to ferret Rico does right it
removes his it's not a lot just trying
to make them bar who is still there yeah
not so yeah so much security you need
really depends on how badly people are
going to want to break it so if you're
protecting you like Bank data or like
banking data I mean it's a Prudential
with which someone somebody could lose
money or something then you're probably
gonna need better security than if it's
just i don't know--it app application so
i mean it all depends on the case the
office you do your code and you install
your credentials encrypted and you take
all these measures then definitely it's
going to take a very very determined
cracker to actually get the information
so you can ever hope for a hundred
percent security can just make it very
difficult yeah and if you really do want
extra security you know what I'd
recommend is using x509 client
certificates and Android devices have an
API that allows you to go and add
additional certificates to the system
key store which has additional levels of
protection compared to most other
storage on the device that being said
the ey story for x509 on any device
android you know your desktop computer
anything has never been conserved that
user friendly so you really do have a
security a security need it is an option
though yeah because here there's also
this business requirement that user
simple city it is also very important i
mean users should only be able to key in
username password once during some kind
of registration flow and then the things
should just work basically like you have
like with an oauth2 application where
you kind of log in to service you get
this access token refresh token and then
you're good to go but yeah so in that
case I'd say the most likely what you're
looking for is to just go and store a
randomly generated off token generated
for this new user session which is the
new it basically once they've logged in
until they've cleared data on that or
reset their password
and then make sure you do storage within
the applications data directory on
internal storage and you mark it as
private every now and then we'll see
somebody try and store credentials on
the SD card which is a very bad place to
put them because the SD card it doesn't
enforce and boxing but yeah I'd say
that's probably you guys preferences or
okay sorry private shared preferences or
yes that I've got that's sufficient yeah
okay thanks thanks the question baby Oh
see you in about 12 minutes left let's
try a little moderator question here
from Nick and Chicago I'd like to make
an application detective other apps are
installed and offer an option to launch
them from within my app is that possible
I'm having deja vu that sounds like
something we've answered before yeah
it's not only possible it's actually
super easy all you have to do is query
the package manager and I mean I assume
you're going to have some sort of
internal list of what of your
applications a just corey package
manager will return a list of installed
applications yeah it management yeah and
even just search for thing if you start
off your packages you know calm my
company right I scruffty that list and
find everything that's going on my
company I think you can actually just
filter and have a return to filtered
well yeah of course then you have got
foot you know come my company my app
actually corresponds to a sort of a
human readable name but to do that you
can actually then go a step further and
check you can actually look inside of
that applications resource table and
query for its you know its list of
strings or just ask what the application
reports is title to so yeah as long as
your applications are signed with the
same developer signature you can
actually go and retrieve resources from
other apps on the system so that also
gives you a lot of additional
functionality there but yeah first step
is take a look in package manager
alright thanks for that question anybody
else on the Hangout have any question we
haven't heard from today
one that I if I can yes DVD fee left to
see Debbie yes hey I I want to ask about
a how many blood of connections can a
android supports immune taneously that's
a good question i don't know how many
blue connections can invigorate support
simultaneously i think that's more of a
hardware yeah limitation then assault
yeah I want to say it's gonna be
divisive I specific why should the zone
of a specific yeah unless asked about
the so let's ask about the galaxy nexus
for example well I I don't think anyway
this room can actually answer because we
were we were the experts in app
development or not the people who
actually build the devices that's a
different team so yeah it's right next
to us but you know we'd have to actually
pull them in here and ask them so it's
not something I think we actually
publish either so yeah yeah so we're
software guys not hardware guys well
we'll have to love to defer to them um
let's try another get about 10 minutes
left so let's take another question from
moderator here anyway cut down on the
number of emails sent by google checkout
and relations and android apps what you
don't like our email i didn't want to
work in to vote yeah we do there's
people dedicated their writing those
emails but anyway i get spam daily by
canceled by google messages whenever the
customer declines payment does a credit
card verification or ask for refund to
by nikolay and denmark that's why i
think we we always think that more
information is better than less and
immediate you can always create the
gmail filter and just filter those
messages and put them into the correct
bins so that way you don't trash if you
really don't exactly what or a special
being called Treach but i mean this is a
this can be useful if you need to search
for them one day like there might be one
day where you need to search for a
particular order and see if it was
cancelled or not so i might be useful to
have that I'm going to briefly change
this to gmail user off the salaries you
can say just just pop open windows
emails the other thing Google menu
option that says filter
messages like these and then say skip
inbox and maybe add a tag if you want or
send the trash or there are checkboxes
you can pick exactly what you want to do
never first they might not be using
gmail it true it's considering that it's
a google account that's receiving these
it doesn't have to wake email them right
you can rate google accounts that are
not tied to gmail that is true it is at
least a semi-liquid if you're using
gmail that's how you doing and in fact a
lot of companies do that because they
have the corporate mail system so yeah I
mean most systems do have the ability to
filter mail and I do agree with you we
probably should have a check box to go
and control how frequently these
messages are sent sadly we don't so I'll
take that as feedback for the check out
gmail pass it along for you but in the
meantime the short term mitigation is to
use whatever filtering the functionality
exists in your mail client so sorry
about that right short answer email
filters are your friends take advantage
of them I don't think we've got anybody
knew and hang out so take another
moderator question Jason Nashville asks
what does calling detach and a fragment
and fragment transaction actually do
when also adding the transactions the
back stack on detach is never triggered
in the fragment in this case but if
you're actually in the Hangout I'm
really curious to know why you are
adding a detached to the fact static
Jason re they're calling Jason yeah
silent I don't think he's here now yeah
say Oh speculate um see I i I'm yeah I'm
really curious what you're trying to do
to we were discussing this for a few
minutes before the show and none of us
could quite figure out what the use case
here is I'm actually typically really
good at wild speculation with very
little device it a lot about you it's a
gift what can I say both with this one I
couldn't actually um and unfortunately I
don't know the answer to the question
yeah regardless of the purpose behind
that behavior yeah i mean my
understanding is yeah actually I wonder
if not I'm drawing a blank here I really
can't think of a good use case I mean
that's so normally on detach gets called
when your fragment is detached from
activity that contains it so that's
something normally the activity should
do is my understanding yeah so um
whatever it is you're trying to do if
you can listen more context feel free to
pop on the air we'd love to hear it and
maybe we can give you a better answer
but the short version is don't do that
right otherwise no just boil it
speculate about why are you doing in so
far as an unproductive so let's move on
really good it to speculate or that's
not even that good today okay okay with
the hangout we got from Sidon and Nancy
France i discovered that multiplying two
linear gradients doesn't work on ICS as
expected in comparison to pre ICS on my
color picker the bottom is in black
doesn't appear only wipe new compose
shader eval shaders that cheater porter
shader mode shader multiply share ok i'm
on this one sir yeah so so for the more
sugar the best guest we have is tried
disabling hardware acceleration for your
app shaders are not supported very well
with hardware acceleration enabled and
as a result as possible as you've hit
one of the use cases that hardware
acceleration does not actually support
so try turning that off it might be
enabled on a per-app basis in which case
you can go into the flag in your
manifest barring that there's also a
option in developer options and system
settings that will force this so you
could have that on too it's off by
default but you know sometimes people
did turn it on it is in developer
options for a reason it does break
things occasionally for the same reason
that's why it's an opt-in setting for
your app but there there is a basically
just added flag to your manifest saying
that you don't want hardware
acceleration and see if that fixes your
problem another advice is a jacket furor
manifester doesn't have any density
equals false because i've seen a couple
of cases where I just setting any
density on on and on the Android
manifest generate some weird graphics
bugs and that's and that's because I
think any density equals false makes the
calculations for ax
reference coordinates a little off so
you shouldn't be using that anyway
because it says mostly deprecated but
just just make sure that you're on that
you're not using it okay thanks for that
question let's see link from Chicago
says I'm making a game using OpenGL ES
is there a good example somewhere on how
to recreate the OpenGL ES context and
reloading textures after a pause and
resume targeting 2.2 and above including
Google TV no Jay and I thanks actually
yeah we have a game in our samples
called replica island it was written I
want to say two years ago by a team
member at the time Chris pro who just
wanted to make a sort of general game
showing general best practices for SDK
ndk hardware acceleration OpenGL like
all the stuff that goes into writing a
good game so the name of the game is
replica island and it's in the samples
area of the SDK right and they should be
it there's an example of that that kind
of yes are there yes yes table take was
in the coen there's an example in there
he asked we should so just nudging it
that that's where the answer is that's
the pink check out all right about three
minutes left so we've got a couple more
time for poking more questions let's
take a anybody else in the Hangout
actually want to ask a question nice
wish to the day I know I've already
asked some question but could I possibly
just ask sup maybe suggest something to
the Google team so I've spoke to a
couple of people on XDA in the past and
that that they have this problem with
screen burning and I'm wondering is that
because they have their screens
brightness set too high and if that's
the case is that possible thing right
just a notification that Google could
are two androids so if people turn their
brightness up full it will warn them
that they may get scream burning screen
burning because they're kind of
brightness up too high is that so the
pixels are to brighter on AMOLED
displays and not just tend to make some
of the pixels look a bit yellow EO where
the white pixels are being the past
really bright I think she never
experienced any min devices may I
usually have a device there's an
envelope screen I mean it seems like a
reasonable request though if that's
actually yeah like it isn't it causes
probably a major just temporary
discoloration if you bring up something
like a white picture on screen and zoom
in you may see a slightly tinted part
where there was previously white pixels
for long periods of time like for
instance a but a battery percentage
think i have on my screen on the
international galaxy s2 sorry uh I have
Asperger's syndrome so my I'm not really
great no no no it's quite all right all
right I understood your singing um so um
yeah I mean that seems like a reasonable
request like like I said none of us here
are hardware guys so as far as yeah
actually how the the screen control
works I don't think any of us are the
right person to actually implement that
change but is something we can pass
along for you I just saw a possible
notification would have been something
that you would have been more software
side well it is but it's still spring
related right so yeah I mean it's it's
outside of this realm of app development
is what I'm saying so yeah we're still
on Thrones would make that change we can
pass the long to the folks who would
okay thank you sorry only great okay um
word princess right up to three o'clock
so i think we're sign off thanks for all
the questions today we'll be back again
next week 2 p.m. pacific to take your
emotions again and thanks for joining us
all right see everyone thank you
you